if you're trying to lose weight is
hunger inevitable the sensation of
hunger is not necessarily an accurate
measure of a calorie deficit for some
people hunger can be an indication that
your body is asking for more fuel than
you are giving it but other times our
hunger cues can be misaligned with our
body's true needs so for example when
you've underslept your hunger hormones
increase and your satiety hormones
decrease when we're stressed our
cortisol levels climb and we suddenly
get cravings for high calorie food even
if this does not align with our
physiological needs another thing to
consider is what you are eating to lose
weight if you're used to eating 2500
calories of Highly processed foods that
spike your blood sugar and make you
hungry again soon after there is a good
chance that you will feel just as full
if not more so on a 2,000 calorie diet
of protein fiber and healthy fats this
is why I created my Hunger crushing
combo because when you add these satting
compounds to your diet you naturally
Edge out the foods that Supply only
small bursts of energy resulting in
Greater satiety for fewer calories